hi welcome and thank you for joining us
in this session where we think about
advanced ngs solutions to
monitor and gain insights for sars kobe
2. i
am chris kenros and i will be walking us
through this discussion
i work in global market development at
thermo fisher scientific
it's worth mentioning at thermo fisher
scientific that our mission is
really to help our customers make the
world a healthier cleaner
safer place and when we think about
something like a pandemic
there really is no truer mission than
helping our customers make
all of us safer so and healthier so with
that i'd like to say thank you
on behalf of our company and to tell you
that we take this very seriously and
that we're here for you
we take pride in this mission and of
course the pandemic that i'm referring
to
is the one we're all living through
right now this is the cova 19 infection
which is caused by the sars kobe 2
virus and this virus has
come out very quickly believed to have
started in wuhan china
where people began to fall ill in
december of 2019
by february 22nd of the following year
there were already nine assembled
genomes from patients in this region
but assembly of this genome using ngs
technology is by no means limited to
china it's now happened in
every region of the world and in nearly
every country
if we take the example in south america
the first case was confirmed on february
26 in sao paulo in brazil and by
february 28th that genome had been
published and so this is truly
collaborative science we're all working
together in this
no one's withholding information and for
that we thank the scientific community
when we think about how
mgs can be used for viral research
there's really three phases where this
content becomes
helpful the first is an identification
so what is it that's making us sick
and if it has a name how's it mutated
what do we know about it if we don't
have a name for it let's give it a name
and let's quickly assemble a genome so
that we can all study it
and understand how to tackle this thing
that phase moves very quickly it was
essentially complete by
early february of 2020. now as the time
of this talk which is september
2020 we're really in phases two and
three which
feed into each other in our virtuous
cycle the first is to use ngs to
research potential vaccines and
therapeutics this is where we look to
understand host response to potential
candidates
but also to continue to monitor that
virus through viral surveillance
and here we use ngs to understand very
quickly in real time
is that virus mutating what is the path
of that transmission
and how do we best attempt to understand
where
particularly virulent strains will go
next and so the remainder of this talk
is really going to focus on these two
phases
this is where we are as a scientific
community this is where we are as a
health community
and so this will be the focus of the
next 25 minutes one of the technologies
you're going to see
discussed today uses a different
approach toward library preparation for
mgs systems and that is
that we made the observation back three
four years ago
that most of the library prep kits on
the market worked in clear liquids and
clear tubes and after somewhere between
a few hours and a few days
you would find out did you successfully
convert your sample
into a library did your robot do its job
effectively
was the sample labeled appropriately was
it quantified
appropriately and so this is a really
difficult way to process such important
samples such as cancer research samples
or in this case
endemic samples there's got to be a
better way anytime you see reference to
a kit called calibri from thermo fisher
scientific
you'll know that that kit contains
tracking dyes
in it each reagent in this kit contains
a different dye and so when they're
mixed
properly they change color and you can
see that here
how do you use this well the calibri
kits are really helpful in a couple of
different situations
one they allow you to work much more
quickly because you don't have to go
back and remix everything
just to make sure that that step was
completed efficiently
they also allow you to check on your
robot if your robot uses a multi-channel
pipettor
it tells you immediately prior to
library quantification and sequencing
if all of those samples completed the
process as expected
but it also allows you to do simple
things such as
work with someone who's learning library
preparation or
even yourself if you've been doing this
for years you know that when you're
standing at an ice bucket
preparing libraries to throw onto the
sequence so quickly
if somebody interrupts you to ask a
question and you look up
you have to look back down and hope that
you remember correctly where you were
you don't have to do that here here you
literally just hold it up to the light
you can see the colors immediately just
keep going these tracking guides are
meant to
allow you to work with confidence and
move more quickly
it's an internal qc mechanism the other
thing that we
observed was that it's a lot of time
being spent
gathering all of the materials to
prepare these libraries
indexed adapters come from one vendor a
pcr master mix comes from another
purification piece comes from a third
you probably need to get some additional
spare seals for your plates
that could be a fourth vendor and so
getting all of these materials together
is very time consuming and frankly a
waste of time for labs who are
processing these samples
we made it simple we just put everything
you need into one catalog number
it'll ship at the appropriate
temperature automatically and you'll be
able to
move on and focus on the science rather
than the
preparation to perform science so today
we're going to focus on two categories
within the portfolio in particular
there's four categories overall so we
currently support whole genome
sequencing as well as multiple flavors
of irony sequencing
we also support library quantification
which we'll touch on briefly
and library amplification but the bulk
of our discussion today when it comes to
sequencing the virus is really around
the first two categories
and this is because of the nature of the
virus itself
well we're all looking at these genomes
for different
uh details different aspects in
particular if you're working on a
vaccine
candidate or you're working on a
therapeutic candidate you're probably
looking at the spike protein of the
coronavirus
and that's because while there are
multiple genes within coronavirus this
one
will determine whether or not it enters
our bodies the research is
quite profound at this point and quite
extensive on the importance
of this spike protein and so yes we can
assure you that this pipe protein
is included and the data that you will
receive using these kits when we think
about these phases we're really asking
two questions one are new viral strains
emerging and of course the corollary to
that question would be
at what rate and where and second
what genes mutated to produce this new
strain
so while we wait and see how virulent it
is while we wait to see how infectious
it is
what are the mutations that define that
new strain so that we can begin to
monitor it and share it in real time
with other people
in the community and the images that you
see here are courtesy of nextstrain.org
which offers a fantastic analysis
platform to
share the results samples that were
sequenced with consent
to inform the community and here you can
see an image again from neckstrain.org
where they offer a visualization service
how this works is that scientists around
the world are
uploading genome into a database and so
they're tagged by location and by strain
and then you can actually monitor in
real time as well as
see a progression over a short term of
history say since february
or even since july if you want something
more recent to figure out where these
are transmitting now when the world was
in global lockdown
this may not have been the biggest
concern but now that the world is
reopening
and we understand that this virus is
here to stay this is becoming
a particular area of importance
if you have a strain that you've
identified as a hot spot
in your city you want to be able to
quickly compare
of other cities seen it for how long how
wide did the outbreak get
and to do that you need accurate ngs
data and so
what we're going to focus on today is
how to generate that data very quickly
and inexpensively so that we can all be
informed in real time and this brings us
to viral surveillance and so this is
trying to understand who might be
susceptible
to new strengths and where might they be
traveling
there are many many groups around the
world focused on these questions
this is just one example this is in no
way
comprehensive of all of the teams
working but if we look at just one
example the covet 19 house genetics
initiative
you can see pretty quickly that these
are global consortia and the people who
previously had been focused on
a different aspect of biology perhaps
hla
for example for transplantation are now
contributing their expertise and have
been for several months
this makes us all much stronger by using
ngs and sharing
the ngs results with each other but
contributing our own
understanding of human biology that we
can offer this helps us to move much
more quickly
so let's start with whole genome
sequencing there is a protocol that we
offer it's been optimized to sequence
lars cov2
is designed to achieve three goals one
it allows
the ngs community to truly survey the
virus
this is possible because coverage is
quite
good of the virus it's compatible with
all illumina mgs systems in fact
everything within the colibri portfolio
is fully compatible with all illumina
ngs systems it's designed
for those systems and this is when we
characterize the viral sample
what strain is it do we have the strain
on record
are there any new mutations within the
strain or
sufficient number of mutations to
qualify as a new strain
and this leads us to the second goal
which is the sleep insight
this is really about variant detection
these are those new snips these are
these snips that
we compare against other known strains
and this is true for all samples
but it also allows you to study host
pathogen interactions
the way this protocol is written you
have a choice
you can sequence the sample that you
receive which will contain both the host
and the pathogen this is typically human
and stars cov2
along with the other type of bugs that
travel with us such as e coli
or you can enrich for pathogen it's a
choice
and so this allows us to scale up so
whether you're looking at a pilot study
to prepare for a larger initiative
maybe you're researching potential
therapeutics and you want to get a grasp
around how exactly you're going to
assess these different samples or
whether you're already in the large
scale phase and you need a way to
consistently and reliably achieve
coverage of that virus
without enormous sequencing depth this
is what it's designed for
one of the nice features of this
particular protocol is also that it has
very small
data files it doesn't take a whole lot
of reads to obtain coverage of a virus
and so that allows you to process those
data files very very
fast there's no point in saving time on
library preparation and sequencing
if you just get hung up in informatics
and so this allows you to go
end-to-end much more quickly so here's
the workflow
this workflow is entirely optimized for
sars kobe 2.
on the website you will see the details
of that optimization
for our purpose here let's focus on the
high level optimization
and then you can dig into the details
when you look through the protocol the
first step
is of course verification your pal life
states are going to need to be purified
we recommend the applied biosystems
magmax viral pathogen
mvp one or two nucleic acid isolation
kit the mvp1 and mbp2 are exactly the
same thing the same chemistry they're
just different package
sizes so they allow you to scale from
small to large projects
using the same chemistry very elegantly
after you have purified
rna the second step is cdna synthesis so
here we perform reverse transcription
the data shown in this webinar will use
maxima h minus double stranded cdna
synthesis kit to perform that reverse
transcription
we also support superscript 4 and we can
show you a full data set online we
encourage you to visit us
online to look at the different data
sets the third step is after you have
cdna
turn it into a library this is a really
fast protocol
takes about an hour and a half and the
kit we're recommending
is the in vitrogene colibri ef dna
library prep kit for illumina systems
now eos stands for enzymatic shearing we
also
offer a physical sharing version of this
kit either of them will work perfectly
fine the enzymatic shearing kit is used
here as a proxy
to mean both of them after that you have
a decision
if you wish to focus on the virus and
you really are not interested in host
virus interactions we recommend
enrichment and you can use the kit of
your choice that works with any
enrichment panel
and then after that you go into library
quantification for sequencing and
analysis
if you want to understand host pathogen
interactions
we recommend that you skip the
enrichment step sequence
much more deeply when you get to the
sequencing step so here we look at three
particular sample results now there's
clearly a lot more samples that have
been sequenced but for simplicity
we're just going to show three examples
and so these three samples were
obtained with consent from the centaur
clinic
biobank in lithuania and they were
converted into sequencing libraries
using the maxima h minus kit for reverse
transcription
and calibri es dna library prep kit for
library generation
they were quantified using the calibri
library quantification kit
and then sequenced on a my seat these
were two by 150 base pair runs
on a v2 nano blow cell and so each of
these samples represents a different
donor
from the biobank the first thing you'll
notice is that the coverage
is sufficient without many reads so in
temple 1 we see mean coverage of over
400 fold
sample two again over 400 fold and
sample three
eighteen hundred fold coverage which i
would suggest is probably a bit more
than anybody needs but here's what's
different between the samples
they were all prepared the same way they
started out as different quality
and so you can see that in the number of
aligned reads that were counted
and as a percentage of a line reads so
in sample one
roughly 30 of the reads aligned to the
reference genome
that's because simple one and simple two
actually weren't that great in quality
but we believe you should sequence what
you have and not wait for the ideal
sample
so we went ahead and sequenced them but
for less than a million reads for
example
we were able to get very strong coverage
in 400 volt coverage
this also allowed us to do rather
extensive sniff analysis and variant
detection which you can see here
sample three had higher quality now the
point here
is that you shouldn't have to assess the
quality of your samples
prior to beginning library generation or
prior to beginning cdna synthesis
you should be able to take what you have
put them all through the same process
and look at the results and that's what
we see so in sample 3 this is much
closer to the idealized form
of the sample quality and so you see a
much higher number of aligned reads and
a much higher percentage of rate but at
the end of the day whether you get 400
full coverage where you get 1800 full
coverage all from the same sequencing
run
you have sufficient coverage to
accurately detect the variant
now you'll notice a slight bias towards
three prime coverage
that's actually a result of the rt the
maxima h minus
double stranded cdna kit does have a
slight preference for three prime
ends during reverse transcription when
you move to superscript four
you actually see much more even coverage
and you'll see that on the website so
what is
this kit and how does this work well if
we focus in
on the library generation portion of the
workflow
if we think about library generation we
can look
at the physical sharing kit as an
example in more detail
the enzymatic shearing kit is incredibly
similar with the physical sharing kit
it's about an hour and a half run time
and about 0.4 hours hands-on time the
beautiful thing about this
kit and the es kit is that it's designed
to be
very sensitive at low input so while the
range that you can use here is between
one and a thousand nanograms of cdna
you actually see very consistent results
at either end of the spectrum
pcr-free protocols are of course
available although
for sars v2 samples most people do
perform pcr
because the amount of sample is quite
limited
so when i talk about performance at
either end of the spectrum
from one nanogram to a thousand
nanograms this is what i'm talking about
and so this is a comparison using human
data of smith and indel recall
or precision from one nanogram at 12 pcr
cycles
up to 1000 nanograms pcr free and you
can see the results are very similar
you do see a slight drop in recall for
indel with 12 pcr cycles these
particular samples are actually corial
na12878 so they're controls that way we
can compare against
other options on the market one of the
nice things about these colibri dna
library prep kits
is that they're designed using solid
molecular biology principles what we've
done is we've taken traditional
ligation based approach protocols
and we've simplified them we've removed
steps that weren't needed
we were able to swap in some of our
custom enzymes
for other older enzymes that have been
around for a while
and so what you get is that with a
really rapid protocol
again about an hour and a half you
actually get a completely assembled
genome
including the ends you don't get these
deep yeah
that you can see with other technologies
this is different than what you would
see for example with a transphobic-based
method
where how the transfusion method works
is that there's near random insertion
points throughout the genome
these insertion points tag the p5 and p7
adapters
but because of this near random
insertion process
it's impossible to get a completely
assembled genome
using a transposomic method this has
been shown in a couple of different
areas so if we look at a
correspondingly difficult sample type
and in fact it might actually
be even more difficult to sequence than
the pandemic samples if we think about
cell free dna
a group at masric university in in embol
in europe as well as ctec in a
university hospital in borno did a
fairly expensive comparison of genomic
dna versus
tumor dna versus cell free dna
from donors who had contributed samples
for research purposes
to study chronic lymphocytic leukemia
and what makes
these samples particularly challenging
is that they're
badly degraded they're typically only
170 nucleotides in length and there's
not much
of them so from one ml of plasma per
person
you might get one nanogram a sample of
dna
to study so you really must choose
carefully how you're going to
address these so what they did was they
tested the calibri dna kit
with these very challenging samples
compare them against buckle swabs and
non-tumor controls which are much easier
to sequence because they're much higher
quality
and the amount of sample material
available is much higher and they
sequence them on an aluminum
550 system they chose a high output 300
cycle chemistry
in order to multiplex samples at the
highest possible rate
and what's interesting is that they were
able to detect copy number variation
abbreviated here as cnb in these samples
so if we look at the top normal dna from
buccal swab
you get your coverage if you start to
compare against tumor dna
from these cll samples as 5x coverage
which is not very high for human genomes
and 10 nanogram of input you can clearly
identify copy number variation
noted here in red if we look at the
bottom set of data
we go to the most challenging set the
most challenging sample type
cell free dna from plasma at 6x coverage
but only one mammogram of input you can
still
detect copy number variation from these
samples
what this means is that it opens up the
possibility
to move to liquid biopsy research
samples and still maintain
very excellent cnv detection
at low coverage if you think of the
sample deeply enough 100x coverage 200x
coverage 300x coverage
you're going to determine copy number
variation but it's going to be
very expensive so the ability to take a
very difficult
challenging sample type and sequence on
a load depth
with a low input is impressive this is a
good step forward
okay so we're talking an awful lot about
dna sequencing
to study an rna virus which is sars cov2
why aren't we talking about rna
sequencing well
we support rna sequencing for this
portfolio as well so let's talk about
rna sequencing
here you have three options
and you can see a comparison of the
options here within the calibri
portfolio
so we support all of these options for
research of sars kobe
2. they give you different levels of
information
at different sequencing price points on
one end of the extreme is whole
transcriptome sequencing
this is where you take your sample you
depleted of human mouse
rats ribosomal contents you put it
through 60 million reads or more
per sample and you look to see what you
get
the input here is typically 100
nanograms on the low end
up to about a microgram and it takes
around six and a half hours to complete
ribosomal depletion and library
generation the library generation
portion including ribosomal depletion is
actually quite fast
in the middle is mrna sequencing this
is if you want to detect coding rnas
and gene gene expression and gene fusion
and you can see here this is where you
would start with enriched mrna that you
typically would obtain from oligodt
and on the right end of the spectrum is
a new type of sequencing
called three prime mrna sequencing this
is designed
for when you just want gene expression
if you want to look at gene expression
analysis in the host pathogen study for
example
which you're not so interested in gene
fusions you're not so interested in
non-coding rnas this is a new option in
the market that people are picking up
very quickly because it's
inexpensive it's fast and it's very easy
to analyze
this type of sequencing only needs about
two to five million reads per sample
libraries are generated in roughly four
and a half hours so it's quite
comparable to mrna sequencing
and the input range here is actually
quite sensitive it goes down to 100
picograms of total rna up to 500
nanograms again of total rna
so what is the difference between them
from a performance
perspective well if we take a sample and
in this case the sample was universal
human reference rna and we compare them
and so
in these cases the quality of the rna
speaks tool set or quartz or simplicity
was used to evaluate gene expression
analysis
and we compared gene expression analysis
we compared gene detection
of the three different rna sequencing
methods using this course analysis
and on the high end like we said earlier
whole transcriptome sequencing will give
you the most genes detected
this is because it picks up small rnas
and picks up non-coding rnas it truly
gives you the entire
transcriptome mrna sequencing you get
roughly 25
26 000 genes from the same sample and a
comparable number from three prime
mrna sequencing in this case we used 100
nanograms of input
but you could use one nanogram if you
wanted now there's a couple of
differences here
one is the starting sample you start
with total rna for whole transcription
sequencing
or three prime mrna sequencing but if
you wish to do
mrna sequencing the one in the middle
you do begin with
all ago dt enrichment and then begin
library preparation
so that's performance in terms of gene
detection
what does that look like how do we get
to that from a whole transcriptome
perspective well
the calibri stranded whole transcriptome
sequencing kit
gives you a choice you could do
ribosomal depletion or not
ribosomal depletion is for a human mouse
rat samples
whereas if you have a plant sample for
example
you might wish to deplete the ribosomal
compounds in a different manner
and then move into the calibre stranded
kit for library generation
these are highly stranded libraries and
quite quick actually
with depletion you're finished with
library generation in about six and a
half hours if you perform your depletion
in a different manner
prior to picking up the cleaver kit
you're finished in about four and a half
hours
what's unique about this kit in addition
to being very fast
is the way that it achieves that speed
and the way that it
actually achieves representation of the
entire transcriptome
not just coding rnas and the way this
happens
is that after purification and
fragmentation of your total rna
you go through depletion and you take
your depleted rna
and you add adapters these are helper
adapters what happens
is that rather than adding adapters to
double-stranded cd
we actually add adapters directly to the
rna
this has two benefits the first is that
it removes
entire categories of bias after these
helper adapters are added directly to
the rna
then you perform your reverse
transcription which gives you your
double stranded cdna
and a couple rounds of pcr complete
those adapters and now you've got
full-length index adapters for the
illumina mgs systems
what's nice about this approach is that
priming is not affected by gc
content and so what that means is that
if you have a gene that is lowly
expressed
in low or high in gc content you're
going to get the same sensitivity of
detection
as if that gene has moderate dc content
it's it's not impact and this is
extremely helpful for new insights
particularly
in the area of immunology what about the
other end of the spectrum
well three prime mrna sequencing this is
that new
version that we were talking about
earlier has a very different approach
this approach is specifically intended
to capture
only the three prime end of the
transcript and therefore
this allows you to perform very short
quick
sequencing runs on aluminum systems you
don't need a two by 150 run they can be
quite expensive a 1 by 50 run or 1 by 75
run is all that you need and you only
need somewhere between 2 and 5 million
reads to get the sensitivity of
detection
so how is how is that even possible it's
because
actually during library generation when
the original
rna is first transcribed the transcribed
copy is retained
the original rna is degraded what this
means is that you don't have to perform
length of normalization you don't have
to perform fpkm you don't have to
perform rpkm
because you know that original rna
template was degraded
during library generation and therefore
could not have been copied multiple
times
and transcribed over and over again you
have this beautiful
internal control so that you know that
the data in your library
matches these transcripts in your sample
and so what does that look like well if
we look at gene detection
which is what this kit is designed for
while determining gene expression and
gene detection
how does this work so the difference
between 5 million reads and 2 million
reads the gene detection is actually
quite similar between these two
most people are running 2 million reads
per sample
because there isn't a whole lot of added
benefit to running
5 million rates for a sample the biggest
factor that determines
how many genes are detected and that
sensitivity of gene detection is
actually the input amount
this is actually really helpful because
that means that if you have
very limited amounts of sample let's say
you only have 500 picograms of total rna
that's it can't get any more you're
going to detect two-thirds
of the total gene set as if you had 500
nanograms
of total rna so if you want to either
sequence samples that are very very
limited and still get very sensitive
gene detection this is a good method
or on the other end if you have plenty
of sample you have 500 nanograms of
total rna there's no limit there
but you want to keep your sequencing
costs down by staying around 2 million
reads
it's perfectly viable options so you
have a couple levers to pull here
to determine how many genes you detect
versus how much it costs you
to detect those great for host pathogen
studies
so we've looked at it from a performance
perspective specifically the number of
genes detected
we keep talking about sequencing what
does that mean what you're seeing
here are us list prices from 2020 from
illumina
for sequencing chemistry and so all of
the numbers
and number of reads shown here are
specifically just for the sequencing
chemistry
and that that price is locked we know
what that price is
because you don't need many reads per
sample
you can actually use the miniseq if you
like in comparison
if you were going to run samples on a
noticeable for example
and you batched them together on an s1
flow cell
you would bring your sequencing costs
down to five dollars if you're
performing whole transcriptome
sequencing where you need a minimum of
60 million reads
you automatically know that you're up in
the next week category or higher
your cost is just going to be so much
more expensive
this offers great flexibility at a very
low price in sequencing chemistry
it doesn't work we worked with dr
nicholas minas
at tulane university who studies zika
what he did was he first compared what
type of gene detection would you get
from three prime
mrna sequencing compared to what he was
using previously which was banana string
assay
now nanostring was giving him insight
into roughly 780 genes which is great
that's actually
a large data set for a fairly low cost
for lower price lower sequencing
chemistry lower
all in price he wanted to know how does
that compare to what he would get for
pre-prime mrna sequencing
so the comparison of a pregnant female
versus a male is was never intended to
be a scientific comparison
but just a how much data am i going to
get and you can see he actually was able
to get significantly more
data more gene detection more gene
expression detection
using three prime mrna sequencing
compared to
nanostrength so then he went and he
looked a little bit deeper he wanted to
see
what was in that data and what he was
able to find
from a very low number of reads was
depressed leukocyte mobilization he
could look at enhanced metabolic
reprogramming
and deficient gene tests and run
comparisons
he was really impressed that for such a
low price point and such an easy
protocol
he was able to get really profound
insight now zika is an rna virus
just like stars cov2 and so we
anticipate
that the level of detail and the level
of insight for the same low level of
cost
and effort would be quite similar we do
have a relationship with genealous it's
an external company it's not owned by
thermo fisher scientific but they have
built the calibri stranded rna
sequencing kit
into their data analysis platform and so
we recommend them if you would like
somebody who has already figured out the
informatics and
can scale your operations very quickly
they're a great solution
they're certainly not the only one we
mentioned nextdrain.org
as being a wonderful place to visualize
data on-ramp has
software to support analysis of
coronavirus
samples analysis at this point really is
not the gating factor
it's the ability to process these
samples quickly and inexpensively to get
them
into the analysis phase and that's where
the collaborate mgs kits can help
now after you generate your library
there's still a step before sequencing
and that is library quantification we do
have a qpcr based quantification kit
within the portfolio and so it contains
those visual tracking guides
it also contains master mixes and
pre-mixed standards that way the whole
process goes much more quickly
we've looked at library yield and as
well as
performance in terms of different gc
content and
in different different species ranging
from homo sapiens to e coli
and it's pretty much consistent with
other qpcr kits on the market
it's a very easy switch to go from one
to the other
and so with that we have very rapidly
talked about whole genome sequencing
solutions
through rna sequencing solutions which
were whole transcriptome sequencing for
host pathogen studies
or three prime mrna sequencing for gene
expression studies
again host pathogen or just post or just
pathogen either way
we also talked about how to quantify
those libraries to make sure that your
sequencing run is
successful duplicates are available for
everything that we've talked about
we have a generous sampling program the
only thing we ask is for you to let us
know where we should send it and so if
you would go to
thermofisher.com calibri
samples all you have to do is give us
your address and we'll send you a kit
you'll also receive an email from one of
our technical specialists to offer
support
with that i'd actually like to thank you
on behalf of myself
and our team and our company thank you
for the work that you do
we we really appreciate you and been
hard we know
but we're here for you so please reach
out and let us know how we can help
take care